okay I've got another Infowars Alex
Jones bumper sticker takedown to tell
you about you might remember that a
couple weeks ago Ryan from Rochester
rode in and he said David everyday
driving to work there's an electrical
transformer with an Infowars bumper
sticker on it I want to cover it with
the david pakman show bumper sticker we
sent Ryan a bumper sticker and he did it
and we got pictures well I later heard
from Spencer in Florida and Spencer in
Florida said hey David you know those
big yellow Amazon lockers where you can
either pick up or leave items that
you're returning to Amazon there's a
bright yellow Amazon locker near where I
live and it's got an info wars bumper
sticker of course info worn Wars of Alex
Jones conspiracy theory Fame and Spencer
sent in a picture of what it looked like
and people who were watching plain and
simple you see it's that yellow metal
that the Amazon locker is made of with
an info wars bumper sticker on it and I
sent Spencer a bumper sticker actually
got it for free with his new membership
and it has now been covered that info
wars bumper sticker has now been covered
with a david pakman show bumper sticker
that you can spot from pretty far away
and I want to congratulate Spencer and
of course remind him and everybody else
that I don't know the legality of this I
have no clue whether this thing counts
as private property or not this Amazon
locker
I don't endorse any breaking of any laws
whatsoever
. period but if you do stuff like this
and it's interesting it might get my
attention and it might be discussed on
the program I think we can expect now an
angry rant from Alex Jones he's gonna
take his shirt off get hyped up on male
enhancement pills yeah he's gotta come
after you for this that would be a great
day for the show I hope that that that
happens and listen if you want to do
this if you know of a spot that could
use a david pakman show bumper-sticker
you can get the bumper stickers for free
right now they come in two colors you
can get the black bumper sticker or you
can get the white bumper sticker you can
get them for free with any new yearly
membership I think about a dozen people
have already done this you go to david
pakman.com slash membership you make
sure you were over on the yearly tab
pick the yearly membership of your
choice and then just write to me after
you sign up and say hey
I signed up for a yearly membership I
want the black bumper-sticker here is my
address and to make it even more
enticing for you
you don't even have to pay full price
because we've got a coupon code right
now that will save you 40% off of any
membership this applies to monthly and
yearly memberships that code is vote
soon 18 okay all one word all lowercase
vote soon 18 sign up for any yearly
membership get 40% off and get a free
bumper sticker if you want it and by all
means I want to make sure people know if
you've got interesting bumper sticker
placements please send us pictures
ideally before and after not too zoomed
in so we can actually see the context of
where it is and these have been going
out by the dozens we're actually it's I
almost might have to reorder bumper
stickers within a couple months once
again usually a supply lasts us like a
year and a half and I'm already thinking
if things continue like this I'm gonna
have to order some more all right so get
that done you can also participate in
the political discussions on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t
today's program is made possible in part
by fruit or which is a social
forecasting game for your phone where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
go on the app find a future event you
feel confident enough about to make a
prediction and make a bet on the outcome
that you think will happen using the
apps in game fake currency if your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points you can compete with others
who are making their own prediction to
see who is the best forecaster there's
no real world money or cryptocurrency
involved the fun of butour is
interacting with others and showing the
world your skills at predicting the
future will democrats take the White
House house this year will Trump run for
re-election will trump ever build the
wall you can go ahead and make your
predictions show off your forecasting
skills and there are also monthly
competitions and prizes for top
forecasters and I'm on food tour you can
wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions go
- fruit or dot-com to sign up and make
forecasts it's free it's on Android and
iOS as well as on web browsers and it's
spelled fut you you are calm